hello and welcome to this brief video
this is master of puppets ok get some
drop action I already should learn
another night against the Trump I mean
this is very convenient to play it's not
super exciting really ok just develop
that bishop yeah blacks position years
we are rather convenient and easy
development nothing much to fear but
it's never really interesting ok it's
probably not that easy to get a really
an interesting position against the
Trump a scheme it is a fairly solid
opening in the first place I mean the
some lines are sharp it it's not to be
thought while I'm playing it too I came
let's see what he is doing here maybe
taking him playing before rook c8 is
kind of a waiting move this one okay
Matt I didn't expect that
okay if I've you might take actually
okay not a good idea yeah how is it
possible someone to use them the
weakness of see i am here we can just go
inside let's see i would love to okay
okay take them i would love to get
something to see for that's probably not
easy night b3 is something that he been
very likely I go for yeah that doesn't
zip it so begin with me gay sex hmm not
quite sure yeah it sexy place b5 and
just trades everything off okay let's
play a waiting move and see what he's
doing here just 93 95
maybe you like it okay so I is active
but I try to use those squares like
night a 7d 5d 6d form but tonight a
seven he is going to go a foursome it's
not so easy i would like to play Queen B
5 but I'm blundering be seven in the
process
I'm not sure nitey seven is doing me
anything anything good here maybe I can
try 97 or something okay that was the
idea he wanted to double actually Jim
it's definitely not bad for him I really
have to defend this before i doing and
thinking of anything active i have to
defend here so no that's not a good idea
Wow wrong wrong wrong I probably have to
get in b6 otherwise I don't ever get to
reduce the suppression
yeah maybe I'm okay if I get in b6 and
great right white resigns the tree
doesn't work anyway I was really shocked
yeah but we'd enter the game yeah I can
we just take it there's nothing I don't
sure what what was the idea here yeah I
think yeah he played that nicely I was
just a bit worse and yeah maybe no not
quite sure how I got to go to this
position I was definitely a bit worse
maybe I'm okay if I can push him out
would be six foot and the engine wants
to do this now this this makes sense and
looking at a six so b6 is not not not on
I don't have a don't have a very good
move him something like this just
staying I don't know a bishop it should
be five that's probably probably on my
idea is set after this I'm actually
covering this so I can maybe play Knight
to f5 to the six or something when I'm
under pressure I mean clearly maybe I
really shouldn't have taken down c 3 i'm
a bit surprised that I'm go see in this
position because i don't really see what
what kind of mistake i made all look
like very yeah very normal moose hmm can
I approve here maybe I was thinking of
this just just opening up the sea part
so that i can trade something else I
mean just just to relieve some pressure
like this this this what the engine is
giving but I don't like that is on hmm
now well played by my opponent then
somehow 96 I don't know what what hear
what hear we look down a bit of a bit of
a weird game okay thanks for watching